Stav Erez, thank you for joining me
on my show for the second time.
How are you?
I'm good.
Thank you for having me.
Of course. Of course.
Okay. So, just today we have
the huge fires all over California
so I appreciate you being flexible,
and hopefully by the time that this airs,
there will be no more fires.
But in any case,
thank you for joining me.
With pleasure.
Wonderful. Wonderful.
Okay. So, I have to start again
from the fun fact
because it's so much fun.
And the first fun fact
that you told me about
is the fact that you're able to hold
boiling pots without getting burned.
How is that possible?
Or with getting burned
but without feeling pain, actually.
Yeah, I just don't feel it.
So basically, you can say I'm a hero
and this is my superpower.
I just I can hold it
and don't feel anything.
I will still burn though.
You will still burn.
You actually showed me before
that you had some burn marks
but I have to understand.
Literally you can go and hold
a boiling pot,
but you're not gonna feel the pain?
Yup.
That's just unbelievable,
but that's just the first fun fact.
The second one, which you have
an interesting story, back from the Army
and you discover by chance
that you're colorblind.
Now I have to understand, first of all,
how is it possible
that only at the age of 18 or 19,
you get to a point where you understand
that you're colorblind?
It must not be that severe, right?
So I don't know about severe,
but I was always told
that I have really bad taste in clothes.
So, but yeah, in the army,
just like I was in the intelligence force
and everybody is writing something
from the board.
I'm like looking to the left, to my right,
I really don't understand
what's happening.
And then I just realized
that I don't see anything
because I'm colorblind,
which makes sense,
my father is colorblind,
but for females it's pretty rare.
You need both parents.
Interesting. Okay.
So, you need both parents to be colorblind
for females to be colorblind.
To have the gene at least.
To have that recessive gene
I guess, right?
Unbelievable. Okay.
So Stav, you're an investor
and entrepreneur.
You ran an accelerator.
You're very knowledgeable
about the Israeli ecosystem,
but specifically about
the Jerusalem tech ecosystem,
which I'm especially curious about.
And today you're investing with Labs/02.
So, I'd love to start off
with your journey.
Take me back to the old days
when you are just starting out,
your entrepreneurial experience
in Jerusalem.
How do you make your way?
What are the biggest milestones
towards you becoming an investor
as a part of Labs?
Walk me through that journey.
Sure. So basically,
I consider myself
to be a social entrepreneur.
Back in 2012, I co-founded Siftech
and was the CEO.
It was the first entrepreneurship center
and first accelerator
in greater Jerusalem.
Basically, our mission was to help
young people like us stay in the city
and build companies and startups.
And there were no startups
in the city back then.
So like any pitch,
like what is the pain point?
Like why do you have to create
different mechanisms to have people
stay in Jerusalem?
I love Jerusalem.
Why would people leave it?
So, I think that the biggest problem
for young people
was basically employment.
And so you can work for the government,
but if you want to do anything else
and if you have an idea
and you want to become an entrepreneur
in Israeli startup nation, right. You basically
would have pack your bags
and move to Tel Aviv
because this was
the only ecosystem in Israel.
And we wanted people
to be able to stay in Jerusalem
although they want
to become entrepreneurs.
And we thought that this is a big,
maybe a major milestone
to develop Jerusalem economy.
So we did that in 2012.
Later on we really, we were
a part of the group
that founded a community
of entrepreneurs in Jerusalem.
I think that the next milestone was JNEXT.
Back then, it was
the prime minister office,
the Jerusalem Development Authority,
and the Jerusalem municipality.
So, I founded the project
to develop Jerusalem economy
through high tech entrepreneurship.
My next stop was at OurCrowd.
Okay.
To build basically the platform
for value creation.
To connect all the tens of thousands
of accredited investors
to the portfolio companies
for business development purposes,
but not only for also
for deal flow, due diligence,
and stuff like that.
And then I gave birth
the day after we launched the platform.
The day after you launched. Wow.
Yeah. During OurCrowd's summit.
It was on a Thursday,
and I really remember John
telling everybody,
I was the last speaker and like,
You just wait. Maybe we're gonna have
like live birth on stage.
Luckily we didn't.
Only the day after.
Wow. Unbelievable.
And then during my maternity leave,
I realized that basically my dream
is to do venture creation,
to build companies
based on academic institutions, IP.
And then we founded Labs/02.
So, we're an early stage seed fund
and incubator.
And we invest in early stage companies,
but also we do venture creation.
And we have a partnership
with the Hebrew University of Jerusalem.
And we're working
with professors and doctors
to really try to see
how we can take their technology
and turn it into a company.
Fascinating.
So, I am aware that the default way
of starting a company is
you have a couple of people
who are coming together,
they agree on a problem,
then they think of a solution,
and they go and bring that
and hopefully find a good go to market
and a product market fit.
But what you're saying here is that
with venture creation,
a lot of times you're going
into these academic institutions
and you're taking technology and solutions
that don't necessarily
even have a problem
and you're finding ways to adapt them.
Is that the way that it works?
Basically, yeah.
It's not only that.
It's also like build a team.
So it's everything.
It's really understanding the technology,
trying to think what you can do with it,
and usually you have plenty of ways
of solutions and problems
that it can solve.
Do market research.
Talk a lot with the industry,
and try to understand exactly
which is the biggest problem
that they're solving,
the biggest need.
And then bring in,
along with the professor,
the relevant team.
Usually, by the way,
the professor stays in academics,
not usually, it's always.
He stays in the university.
He becomes an adviser
to ...
Okay. And then
So how is that lifecycle different
than the regular startup?
So, you're helping them
do the market research,
form a team.
And then maybe down the line,
invest, I guess.
Because you're not, it sounds like in the beginning
it's more of a mentorship
type of engagement,
and then it becomes a pre-seed
and a seed stage investment?
Yes. We're really working with them
for a period of time.
This takes time.
Usually when a company comes
and they pitch,
so it will take a couple weeks,
couple of months like tops
to decide to invest.
Here, we're talking about a process
that can take up to a year.
But when we're happy with the results,
we're putting in the money
and we can move forward.
So then how do you divide your time
because it sounds like
if you have a few of those ventures
that are almost a year long process
and there's only a finite
amount of time and resources
that Labs/02 can provide,
how do you divide that up?
So, we invest
in around six companies per year.
We won't do more than two
venture creations per year.
Okay. So you're focusing, so the venture creation
is even more exclusive, is even more selective
than the investments.
For sure. It takes time.
We can't really do six
I wish I could. But I really can't.
Right. 100%.
So, one of the things
that we talked about before,
which was really interesting to me,
is this sort of the do's and don'ts
of an early entrepreneur
going to their first investors.
And I'd love to get your take
on your impression
having met so many entrepreneurs
and so many companies.
What are some of the pitfalls
that you notice
that young entrepreneurs make
as they start their journey and approach
their first institutional funding?
So I actually
have a full lecture about it,
but I'll maybe pick like the best ones.
- I love it.
So, I think that the first one is really
that it's all about
personal connection.
So, a lot of the times entrepreneurs come,
they sit down,
they connect their computer,
and they start to talk.
"So, the problem we're solving
and the solution and"
Guys, wait for a second. Let's talk.
It's like a relationship.
It's not an interview, right?
You need to form a connection
with the person,
because if I'm going to invest,
I'm gonna work very closely with you.
I want to make sure not only
that you know what you're talking about,
that you're tackling a relevant problem,
that your solution is good.
I want to find out, first of all,
who are you
and are you the kind of person
that I want to work with.
So just start
by getting to know the person,
and maybe it can lead me
to how to really connect
and how to approach.
So a warm introduction, I think,
is always the best way to go.
But I think it's really important to say
that even if you don't,
you can't find a warm introduction,
a cold email is okay.
Just do your research.
So, go and see my interview, for example,
for 20 minutes and just write something
about something specifically I said that,
I don't know, clicked.
Go try and find out
if the investor wrote anything,
he did a TED talk.
Go into his portfolio companies
and see which kind of company
he invests in.
So when you're writing an email,
a cold email, just make sure, by the way that's fine,
but just make sure it's not
the same email you're sending everyone
because if an investor gets an email
that he sees that everyone
got the same email, and it's a cold email,
he's probably going to pass from ...
So this is like a small something
that you can do pretty much right away.
I think that another thing is that
you must be proficient in what you do.
So, I know that a lot of people
are starting with
like a story about themselves
and how they encountered a problem,
but I really don't think
that that's enough just to
that you encountered a problem.
It really needs to be something
that you dealt with, you worked with.
Not just something
that occurred one day,
but something that time
you thought a lot about it.
You're proficient in the field
that you're talking about.
I think that this is super important.
I think that
even for pre-seed and seed investors,
it's very important to do
as much as you can by yourself.
So, by the way it's fine
to come to an investor
with a presentation only,
but also, just with a presentation, just show
that you gave it some thought.
That you did your research
as much research as possible.
If I know more about the subject
than you do,
that's not a good thing.
So, really do as much as possible.
And I understand that not everyone
can really put everything on hold
and now focus solely on their company
and build it from scratch,
and that's okay.
You don't have to get to paying customers.
But as much as you can,
try to do on your own.
But there is something
that speaks to this idea
of being scrappy and bootstrapping
and being able to leverage
whatever minimal resources
you have starting out.
And coming with some good foundation,
not necessarily with paying customers.
A lot of times investors
don't even expect to see that
up until the seed or the series-A,
but at least coming with proof
that you as a team can leverage
whatever small resources
a pre-seed investor can provide you,
because those few hundred thousand dollars
or those few million dollars,
they're not gonna be
the deciding factor of whether
you're able to execute well.
They might help you get there,
but at the end, the team,
it's how you leverage
those minimal resources, right?
Exactly.
And we're taking a risk, right.
You're sitting in front of us
and you're selling us a dream.
By the way, I love the job
being an investor,
specifically in the pre-seed seed.
I don't need to start like,
I'm not going to the excel link
Okay. You're ...
I see the ...
I get to see people's dream,
so like, that's the best ... ever, right?
But I'm still taking a risk.
And I do want to see
that you took some risk as well.
So, just try to do as much as possible.
I want to say something else.
Just food for thought.
So I see the relationship,
like I mentioned earlier,
I see it as a two way street.
So, it's not only that you're coming in
and you need to impress me and sell.
I really do think that
what you can do for me,
if you're asking an investor
what he can do for you,
is super valid question.
And I want to see more entrepreneurs
actually ask this.
I want them to understand
that they don't only need money,
they need value
and to choose investors
based on value.
So, I will say I had quote a lot of companies
that I said no to
not because they weren't good,
not because I didn't have
a personal connection,
just because I thought
that I wasn't right investor.
I didn't think that I can bring
additional extra added value.
That's important.
So, this is just a tip
that when you approach investors,
come with the confidence.
Understand that you're coming
into a marriage
and you're choosing the person
as much as he's choosing you.
Right.
Stav, what is your number one turn off?
That when somebody approaches you
You see a lot of companies.
What is like one thing
that really makes you tick,
and not perhaps just you,
but the average investor?
Maybe arrogance, and probably
the biggest problem, I think,
is lack of diversity.
So, I think that a lot of the time
you can see when it's a group of men only
just because they still haven't recruited
the relevant people,
but this is part of their culture.
Or just because they're men
like men and that's it.
I think that this is, by the way,
I think this is a big problem
for our industry.
The lack of diversity is, for me,
it's a big problem.
No, no, definitely. And this is something
that comes up often in this series.
And a lot of others that I've spoken with,
we've spoke extensively about the role of,
the responsibility of having diversity
from both the investor side,
but also the founder side.
And on the opposite side
of this question of
what makes you tick,
what really makes you excited?
So what quality, or what happens
that makes you really excited
when you meet a new entrepreneur
and you're like,
"Wow, this is somebody
that I might really want to work with"?
So, when they're super super excited
about what they're doing and when
I really love crazy ideas, basically.
So the crazier, the better
from my perspective.
But really when you see like this,
I don't know,
this professor from the university,
and he's coming.
And he's talking to you about
like quantum physics.
And he's super excited, and he's sure
that this is the most exciting topic
in the world.
I'm excited as well.
I love it. I love it.
I remember I had a great conversation
with Dror Berman
from Innovation Endeavors a while back.
And their whole thesis is moonshot ideas.
And I was just so inspired
by this notion of investing
based on the idea that
you're only going to go for the companies
that have a shot at changing the world
in a really substantial way.
So I love this idea
of the crazier the better.
But Stav, you gave a tip
that for anybody
who wants to approach Labs/02
should should get to know you better.
So, I'd love to get
to know you better myself.
Hopefully one day I'll also come
and pitch a company to you.
But talk to me a little bit
about what you're passionate about.
So, you see all these different companies,
all the different industries,
what really makes you excited
about the entrepreneurship world,
and what types of projects
do you really get excited about?
So I have to say that
we're pretty generalists.
So, we're excited about a lot of things,
but we are looking to solve big problems.
You called it shooting to the moon
and I actually I love it.
So, it's really hard for me
to pick a specific sector,
but I think what gets me excited
if it's like big ideas
that are going to change the world.
I love the fact that in each one
of my portfolio companies,
I can really see the impact.
We're not impact investors.
This is not what we base
our decision upon,
but still, like if you go through
my portfolio company,
you can actually see
like the how they're going to affect
and change something in the world
each and every one of them.
So, on my personal level,
this gets me excited.
So, I love the fact that people
are thinking like beyond-
Okay. So, you were telling me
a little bit about the portfolio.
I missed it a little bit.
So, just go back and we'll figure out
how to stitch it together properly.
Okay. So, we are pretty much generalists.
So, there's not like one sector
that I could tell
that this is our sweet spot,
although I'm super excited
about NeuroTech.
I think that this is the future.
But I think that we're excited about people
that are coming
that are trying to solve big problems,
that are coming with futuristic ideas,
and, on a personal note,
I love the fact that
if you look at my portfolio,
you can find the impact
that each and every company does.
So, take me back
to the portfolio companies.
You're agnostic.
You're generalists.
This time I'm gonna hear you.
Okay. So, we're pretty generalist.
We're looking for people
that are solving big problems,
futuristic, with deep technology.
But on a personal note,
I really like companies
that have an impact.
We're not an impact fund,
but I love the fact that if you look
at our portfolio companies,
you'll see that each one of them
really is making an impact.
And a sector I would say
that my new passion is maybe NeuroTech.
So, I love that.
Okay. What do you love about that?
Why specifically that?
I think basically we're gonna see,
I think that this is a field
that it's only in the beginning,
and I think that's we're gonna see
much more.
We know very little about our brain,
so we have a lot more to explore.
And I love the fact that until today,
I think that most of the companies
that we saw was very,
you had to put something on your head.
Not to say, in your head.
And we're now going to a phase
where it's going to be
non-invasive completely.
So, you're going to be able
to just make your brain work better
without really hurting him.
So, that's interesting.
I love it. Okay.
So, along the same lines
of getting to know you, I have to ask you
the most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
and why those three specific words?
Okay. So I would say I'm an entrepreneur.
I really like to build things.
I have to say that I don't really like
to manage them afterwards,
but I like to build things.
But that is why being an investor
really suits me.
Alright.
Maybe the second word would be smile.
So, I'm a very happy person
and I smile a lot.
And this is the way
I want to live my life.
So when I was really young,
my mother told me that
if I'm not happy about something,
just walk away.
You don't have to stay in a place
where you're not happy.
And I did that.
So, I smile most of the time I think.
- Wonderful
And the last thing
that describe me, talk.
So, basically it's really hard for me
to shut up.
I love it. Explain a little bit more.
So, I think that I know a lot
about a lot of topics.
So I can talk to you about
all these kinds of different things.
If you try to go in depth to some of them,
maybe it won't work as well.
But I love it.
So, we can jump from one topic to another
and I can really hold a conversation
for a couple of hours.
I love it.
Stav, thank you very much
for your time and generosity.
Thank you for staying
with all the mishaps,
with the fires, and the Internet
but we managed to get this.
And this was just wonderful
and very insightful.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you very much.
You too. Bye.
Wonderful.